Her low freak bitches.
Exactly.
I know nobody has notes.
Everyone has like a little like a business card with three bullet points on it.
And I'm a little more of the,
you know,
the Shandling tons and tons of paper until you're drowning and confused.
Shan.
You know,
that's a sad one man.
Well Fun Dude.
That was oh the best.
And I'm doing a documentary about him now for Hbo.
And so the most fun part about it is he always went to the comedy magic club and
did stand up even in eras where you didn't know he was doing it.
That's where I met him at the comedy Magic Club.
Yeah.
And how was it?
That was great.
Yeah,
he's just,
I mean it was like for me,
I was a huge fan of Larry Sanders show and Larry Sanders show a,
that's where Paul Simms got start producer of news radio.
And so when I,
you know,
when I saw him I was like,
it was one of those ones like,
oh wow,
that's a,
that's actually Garry Shandling right there,
right?
There were Judd Apatow right there.
It's a weird one.
And He,
and you know the comedy magical,
they tape every show since the 80s.
They have every show taped.
And I said,
can you give me the last 50 sets that Gary did?
The comedy Magic Club.
And this is,
you know,
from the last few years.
And no one's ever seen any of these jokes except that people at those shows,
he didn't do him on TV.
He didn't do 'em on talk shows.
There was no special,
some of the funniest jokes you've ever heard.
Just him,
you know,
working on the graph.
How about going around being so funny?
Yeah,
but he,
he did a lot of notes.
He was,
uh,
his discipline guy.
He was in his seventies.
He wrote so many jokes.
I found these binders,
hundreds and hundreds of jokes in every loose leaf binder.
Like a guy sitting at a desk all day just crafting like two sentence perfect
jokes.
Yeah,
but there's like the balance,
right?
There's that,
there's crafting the perfect jokes and then there's just being able to be loose
and fun and hilarious.
Well,
he also used to go on stage with a justice set up and he wouldn't know the
punchline and he would say to setup and hope the punchline came,
which is pretty wild.
He,
um,
you know,
one of the,
one of the great things about doing a documentary as you get to ask people for
footage.
So Seinfeld gave me,
uh,
the dailies for Comedians in cars getting coffee when he interviewed Gary.
And then the people who made the movie comedian about Seinfeld gave me all the
dailies of a sequence that they only use 10 seconds over the documentary,
which was Gary and Jerry going to the comedy magic club and doing sets.
And also there that night as Neil and,
and Chris Rock and there's 12 tapes.
It's all their performances and then their entire conversation for three hours
hanging out backstage.
And it is unbelievable the conversation,
how funny it is.
And,
uh,
there's a moment where Chris rock is doing the joke about how Nelson Mandela got
divorced,
that even Nelson Mandela,
after decades of being in prison,
he could survive that,
but he couldn't survive getting out and being buried.
He gets divorced immediately.
I forgot how we worded it,
but there's a shot of Shandling alone in a green room watching rock do this bit
and as he's doing it,
Gary's like saying what he,
what he's like,
he's guessing what the bit is as rock saying it,
but in all of Chris Rock and it's a,
it's a really beautiful moment and that's what the best part of doing in this
documentary is it just finding little magical moments that no one would ever see
if you didn't dig deep.
What made you decide to do this?
No,
we did a memorial for Gary when he died at the Wilshire Ebell theater,
like a thousand people showed up and I made about five mini documentaries about
Gary to show in between the speakers and I thought,
oh,
this is a documentary.
I should just expand this.
And now it's like,
now it's like the Oj doc of Gary.
It's a big long epic documentary.
I think people don't realize how good the Larry Sanders show was.
Yeah.
Like people forgot,
you know,
if he'd go back and watch it again,
I mean that was a revolutionary show.
When it was on the air,
it really was,
well,
people don't go backwards.
Like my kids don't go backwards digging that far.
Like to them,
you know,
looking backwards means I'll watch all of parks and REC,
right?
They're not taking into the 90s.
Right?
Uh,
they go to 2015 and people forget that when the Larry Sanders show came on the
air,
you know,
the shows on Hbo,
it was like a first and 10 are not necessarily the news or dream on,
you know,
Gary was the first show on HBO that made Hbo go,
Oh,
this is what HBO should be.
We should be the quality,
uh,
network with the old,
with this kind of groundbreaking television.
And,
uh,
you know,
Gary was a guy who got offered all the talk shows.
He got offered to replace Letterman.
Um,
he was hosting the tonight show for Johnny.
Uh,
Haman Leno would,
would,
uh,
take turns doing it.
And he decided he rather satirize it then do it.
And he wanted to explore the people and not be a talk show hosts.
He wanted to show like the world of ego.
That is not just talk shows but just show business.
He was fascinated with people's need for attention,
his own need for attention,
his own vanity and narcissism.
And he wanted to explore that and,
and satirize how we just want to be liked so badly.
Like what we do to be liked,
which prevents us from actually feeling love.
Cause we're so obsessed with approval.